the latest on the economic recovery from
the pandemic on friday we learned the
nation added a better than expected 850
000 jobs in the month of june though the
overall unemployment rate edged up
slightly to 5.9 percent hourly wages
rose
3.6 from a year ago president biden said
the numbers provide something else to
celebrate this fourth of july
this is historic progress pulling our
economy out of the worst crisis
in a hundred years driven in part by our
dramatic progress in vaccinating our
nation and beating back the pandemic
as well as other elements of the
american rescue plan
today okay here to talk about the jobs
and numbers and the ongoing recovery is
cbs news senior business
analyst jill schlesinger who is back in
studio for the first time since march
good to see you jill um let's start with
this so more jobs than expected
but unemployment went up what gives well
these are two different surveys one is a
survey that goes out to employers and it
says did you hire more people
yes 850 000 more the other goes to
households and the household survey says
hey are you employed are you actively
looking for a job and if you're not
actively looking you're not counted as
part of the labor force and that can
mean
that the unemployment rate moves up and
down again a tenth of a percent not a
big deal
we do have a ways to go three and a half
percent was the unemployment rate before
the pandemic but
we have made progress we were over 14
percent
last april well folks aren't going back
to work and now a government report says
folks are quitting their jobs at a rate
they haven't seen since
2000 one what gives and what are
companies doing
to keep people on their payroll this is
like the conundrum
of the labor force question and here's
the the temporary
aspect of it we know people are
receiving these extra benefits through
the federal government right 300
a week that allows them to stay on the
sidelines and maybe take their time
looking
we also know there are people who had
child care issues we also know that
there are people who are really worried
about the virus maybe because of what's
going on in their home
but a longer term issue that's really
fascinating economists tell me
we didn't have international migration
for so long that was a source of a lot
of workers
and get this pandemic retirements
soared we saw more than 3 million people
retire
during the sorry two million people
retired
during the pandemic that accounts for
the drop in the labor force we saw a 3.4
million drop in the labor force 2
million is retirements so it's a huge
change and then so when you're a company
then what are they doing to try to keep
the people that are there
and then maybe recruit more even still
well you know the tech companies are
always the leading edge of this
early on you know we the ones that you
would expect microsoft and apple and
google they said ah stay home take your
time
right but now there are more and more
companies saying we want to adopt a
hybrid model
we saw a recent poll that was really
interesting 39
of respondents said if i can't get
flexibility i want a new job
and so more companies we're talking
about pepsi and verizon
even financial firms like the ubs just
announced this
citigroup said we'll do a more flexible
schedule but wasn't what was it morgan
stanley that said
if you can go eat in dinner in new york
you're coming into the office yes
slashing salary yeah exactly the ceo
james gorman had said that
what's interesting about it is i think
these other companies are saying here's
a way that we can
differentiate if they're going to be so
hard line our competitors at morgan
stanley and goldman sachs and jpmorgan
chase
then why not come over here interesting
citigroup is led by a female ceo
she has determined that she thinks she
wants to be the place where working moms
want to be
and i think a hybrid model could be the
key just remember a lot of people
up and down the income stream they are
reconsidering their options this
pandemic has created a psychological
emotional and family hangover
people are reconsidering their options
if you work on airplanes or in
restaurants or hotels you can't do that
hybrid model you have to be there
that's exactly right there are certain
industries that don't lend themselves to
it but to
others you know what maybe there is a
way a middle ground that will be
interesting
we have to see how this develops i mean
these are early days in the recovery so
i think
it's going to develop further right jill
schlesinger thank you so much
great to be here